نعم في هذه المناطق محمد التي تقابل عمليا
منطقتي بيت حانون وبيت لاهيه في شمال قطاع
غزه هناك عمليات تفجير متواصله ينفذها
الجيش الاسرائيلي لعدد من المنشات
والمباني السكنيه والمنازل قبل قليل فقط
رصدنا انفجارات عنيفه في الاطراف الشماليه
لبيت حنون ولكن ايضا في الاطراف الجنوبيه
لهذه ال البلده وهذه العمليات متواصله في
الحقيقه منذ عده اسابيع اي حيث يواصل سلاح
الهندسه في الجيش الاسرائيلي تفخيخ عدد من
المباني والمنازل السكنيه ومن ثم تفجيرها
وهذا ما كنا نرصده عبر ما ينشره الضباط
والجنود من داخل ارض الميدان لعمليات
تفجير واسعه لهذه ال المباني غالبا يقول
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي بانها منشات
وبنى تحتيه تابعه لحركات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لكن من الواضح انه يتم تسويه
المنطقه بالارض بالكامل من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي تنفيذا لخطه تحدث عنها العديد
من المسؤولين السياسيين والعسكريين في
اسرائيل مع بدايه هذه الحرب بانه سيتم
تحويل هذه المناطق المحاذيه ل الشريط
الحدودي سواء كان في المنطقه الشماليه او
في المنطقه الشرقيه لحزام امني وللمناطق
عازله وهذا ما يؤكده صباح هذا اليوم تقرير
نشر في صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت يتحدث عن ان
الجيش بدا يستكمل عمليات التدمير
وتسويه الاف المباني والمنازل في المناطق
المحاذيه للشريط الحدودي تحديدا شمال وشرق
قطاع غزه
وقال ال التقرير بانه حتى الان بالفعل تم
تدمير الاف من هذه المباني تحديدا في حي
الشجاعيه الذي يقابل لبلدات في غلاف غزه
منها ناحل العوز
وكفار عزه وايضا الاطراف الشرقيه لمنطقه
بيت حانون التي تقابل مدينه الزورو وايضا
تم تدمير مباني عده في الاطراف الشماليه
التي تقابل بلده نتيف ه عسرا في منطقه
غلاف غزه بطبيعه الحال الادعاء وفقا لما
اوردته هذه الصحيفه هو ان هذه المناطق
كانت تكشف ال البلدات في غلاف غزه ويتم
استهداف مواقع فيها من خلال الصواريخ
المضاده للدروع بالاضافه الى انها قد تكون
مناطق قريبه ايضا لعمليات قنص على في داخل
البلدات الحدوديه لكن الصحيفه ذكرت ايضا
محمد بان مثل هذه العمليات سينفذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في مناطق اخرى تقع في جنوب
قطاع غزه على الشريط الحدودي المحادي
لمنطقه الغلاف تحديدا في منطقه خزاعه كذلك
قامت الصحيفه بنشر صور لهذه المناطق
المدمره واجرت مقارنه ما قبل الحرب وما
بعد الحرب تظهر حجم الدمار الكامل اي
ووثقها بطبيعه الحال وحده خاصه في سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي والاستخبارات العسكريه
ويقوم بنشرها لكن في في في الواقع نحن
ايضا يعني تمكنا في اكثر من مره من الوصول
الى المناطق المحاذيه لمنطقه الشجاعيه
تحديدا وهي التي شهدت اكبر عمليات تدمير
لهذه المنازل بالاضافه ايضا لما نرصده
الان في منطقه بيت حانون عمليات تدمير
واسعه يوصلها اي سلاح الهندسه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي لتدمير المباني والمنشات وهذا
طبعا عمليا سيكون ضمن الخطط المستقبليه
لعوده السكان الى هذه المناطق والتي حتى
هذه اللحظه تصر اسرائيل على عدم السماح
للسكان من المناطق الشماليه بالعوده الى
هذه المناطق وهو ما جاء على لسان رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو يوم امس خلال
لقاءاته مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ب ك في
وقت طلب فيه بلينكن بدء السماح لسكان هذه
المناطق بالعوده اسرائيل تصر على الرفض
ويتحدث الجانب العسكري الاسرائيلي عن انه
سيكون من الصعب عوده سكان هذه المناطق
بينما تتواجد قوات لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في المناطق الشماليه ويدعي بان
ذلك سيعرقل عملياته في الشمال رغم